it's time for seen and unseen will we
reveal the stories behind the headlines
for that we turn to Fox News contributor
Raymond aroyo all right Ray Biden
announced a big artificial intelligence
executive order
today well Laura watching this I thought
this executive could have used some
orders from artificial intelligence AI
is all around us and AI is helping the
National Weather Service predict weather
events helping web Tech the web the web
t scope manag half a million miles of
galaxies away billions of light years
away I found out when I turned on my
phone and saw that I thought my God what
is this science fiction I'm serious AI
is helping millions of computers find
the shortest route home as
well good Lord I'm hoping AI can help
the president find the shortest route to
the end of his speech Laura I mean he
passed the he he signed this executive
order today to limit ai's reach the
problem is it styes American innovation
and makes it the supplicant of DC
bureaucrats this is not going to help us
in the long run well did he call it the
web telescope isn't it the Hubble yes do
he thinking of web Hubble I don't
understand who knows but look his by his
performance today Laura was so unsteady
even K Harris couldn't keep a straight
face like you and there are many ways to
define the leadership of our President
Joe
Biden as even a quick review of his most
recent as even a quick review of his
most recent victories makes clear all
right there is a web there is a web T
there is a web telescope that I didn't
know about okay so Biden is I stand
corrected by Joe Biden but see the first
that's that may be the first and only
time that ever happened Laur but what
victory is kamla Harris talking about
the border is being overrun China Russia
and Iran are ascended we're broke
where's the victory well it's depending
on the meaning of the word Victory then
you have toine look there's clear
concern about Joe Biden's ability to
govern even in Democratic circles Bill
Whitaker of 60 Minutes questioned Harris
about it this weekend well first of all
I'm not going to engage in that
hypothetical because Joe Biden is very
much alive and running for reelection oh
thank you for the
reassurance you're well I guess I guess
because he has a pul Laur he's equipped
to run the the nation and the world this
is not something you want to hear from
your vice president that he's very much
alive thank you for that ringing
endorsement comma but don't worry
Raymond because she's has a full command
when you really listen to her of all the
complexities of foreign policy and
what's the message to Iran
don't as President Biden said just don't
exactly one word pretty
straightforward I love that Biden
Doctrine lawyer for the Middle East
don't don't what don't make a bomb don't
wear a burka don't do what this is the
most ridiculous thing and they keep
repeating it like it's a great
Innovation or something creative and
wonderful look the Democratic party has
no confidence in kamla Harris which is
why you see Gavin Nome traing all over
on a week-long tour of China this is the
California Governor's chance to show
that he can move with ease on the
international Court they should have
warned the Chinese
[Laughter]
[Music]
children all right free throws that's
the only time he wants us to compete
with the Chinese and take them down
that's that's it that's it for that's
the great fall of China that's what you
call that what a doofus I mean the poor
man don't try to show your ease with the
little children when you're like 20 feet
tall you look ridiculous by way the well
the good thing is that Gavin actually
broke his fall with his hair so that was
good that was they didn't actually I
thought he broke his fall with that
child but we won't quibble
congratulations or in order tonight
marks the sixth anniversary of the
Ingram angle I can remember that very
first show in Washington and I have to
say you have been ahead of the curve
since the very beginning coid politics
crime homelessness you really set the
pace with this program for so many in
the media so congrats apparently I I've
even gotten my earrings to stay on they
usually don't fall off now progress
progress only took Sam said they fell
did they fall off Sam once or twice just
once so far this year Sam's keeping
track no it's everyone behind the scenes
makes it work every night Tommy Sam and
David and all the Michaels and Gabby and
everybody uh they do such a great job
and we love our team including you
Raymond all the way in New Orleans great
to see you Raymond thank you happy
annivers Happy 6th anniversary hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else